il est 19 heures 14 c'est l'heure de
notre page était consacré ce soir aux
préparatifs du festival de loire alors
les artistes à fédérer des dizaines de
personnes pour construire une
embarcation très spécial ça se passe à
la salle fl et on retrouve sur place
arnaud moreau tout de suite bonsoir
arnaud bonsoir on est dans un univers
digne de valériane ou encore d' avatar
on est dans l'univers de la cua nef
salle eiffel à orléans où on a durant
près de trois semaines construit cette
oeuvre
chacun est venu apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice un travail initié par
l'artiste jacques ellul nous avons
assisté justement aujourd'hui à une
séance
je vous propose de voir ce reportage
réalisé avec isabelle racine et jean
guéguéniat nous ne sommes pas dans un
film de science fiction mais bien ça les
fait la orléans depuis près d'un mois
on s'affaire ici pour préparer un drôle
de vaisseau la couenne f une oeuvre
monumentale où viennent se greffer des
éléments de récupération c'est pas la
même chose que de la pierre de l'argile
ou du bois où on va où on veut aller là
on a envie de compléter une forme qu'on
a mis par une autre forme dans l'espace
mais on sait très bien ce qu'on voudrait
mettre le problème c'est qu'on l'a pas
forcément
donc c'est un peu en permanence importe
où je te dévore donc il faut avancer
avec ce qu'on a initié par jacques l'élu
ce travail participatif impliqué près
200 personnes durant environ un mois
parmi eux alain il a tout de suite adoré
le projet et vient régulièrement apporté
sa pierre à l'édifice il va ya vraiment
pas rien de technique et c c'est très
simple comme tout le monde peut
participer
et puis oui de l'improvisation 6e pas
spécialement réfléchi
moi je réfléchis pas tout temps en tout
cas
et après l'assemblage place à la
peinture
c'est dans cet espace dédié que sont
entreposés les parties les plus
imposantes de l'oeuvre je suis passé de
l'autre côté de l'atelier pour vale a
rectifié tous les endroits où il fallait
il fallait que ça prenne sens et c'est
vrai que c'est en faisant la peinture du
coup que on apporte l'unité ajoute la
structure et c'est là qu'on commence à
comprendre ce que ça va donner au final
jacques l'élu n'en n'est pas à sa
première oeuvre monumentale à chaque
fois sa volonté il a même faire
réfléchir le public sur la notion de
surconsommation via la récupération on a
souvent dit que j'étais la plus grande
agence matrimoniale pour objet c'est à
dire à travers le temps et l'espace je
faisais se rencontrer des objets qui
n'était pas fait pour faire un coucou
dans une cuillère absinthe un bout de
lego à travers le temps et l'espace donc
voilà donc je suis le facteur cheval de
la galaxie et notre facteur livrera ce
colis à partir du 14 septembre prochain
pour le festival de l'oie et pour parler
de ce projet titanesque
on est avec philippe violanti directeur
artistique du festival de loire bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous alors
justement que quel a été le parlez-nous
de l'historique de ce projet comment est
née l'idée de ce projet voit la relation
avec jacques l'élu est une relation
ancienne
on a fait beaucoup de choses ensemble et
on s'est connu à travers cette idée de
mariée culture environnement et en
travaillant sur le fessier de leurs de
on s'est dit pourquoi pas inventé un
acco nef qui soit propre au festival une
espèce d'objet totalement imaginaire où
les gens puissent aussi peuvent aussi
s'investir transposer leur propre
imaginaire et voilà qu'on a comme ça un
objet qui fera presque 25 mètres de long
postée sur lesquels oui alors il sera
postée à la fois donc qui est du
châtelet devant le continent expliquez
nous un peu comment ça va se passer
il ya c'est toute une histoire il ya ce
qu'on appelle d aqua siens et d aqua
sienne qui seront présents autour des
objets il ya un immense objet donc c'est
à quoi neuf qui sera pour ceux qui
connaissent au niveau d'une exposition
et du bateau la voix et puis après le
continent il y aura aussi un rappel
quelques à quoi tient à quoi sienne qui
seront là
pour pour marier les choses autour de ce
grand site du festival de l'oie alors je
crois savoir que beaucoup de gens
participent et notre tout un tout type
de public a pu participer à la
réalisation de cette oeuvre
oui c'est ce qu'on aime à dire de 7 à
107 ans tout le monde peut venir
petits et grands et c'est une oeuvre
participative hausse lisez en gros sur
le mois une centaine de personnes sont
venues apporter qui a tué ben attia
d'arrosage peu importe plein de choses
qui peu à peu transforme
l'objet qui devient extrêmement complexe
mon impression c'est une machine
vraiment hyper sophistiqués ce qui est
le cas d'ailleurs mais fabriqué
uniquement de matériaux de récupération
les pépites pour finir un mot sur le
message c'est attention à la pollution
respectons la loire à la nature si on
veut bien sûr c'est aussi la beauté des
objets ce qu'on peut en faire
c'est comment l'imaginaire peut porter
les choses et aller loin avec le public
dans le cas d'un festival comme celui ci
vient tout dernier mot après on ne sait
pas ce que deviendra après une oeuvre
fait sa vie en lui souhaitons nous
souhaite vraiment longue vie et elle
peut comme c'est arrivé dans d'autres
projets retrouvez des soirées électro
des musées des grands parcs enfin voilà
tout est possible merci beaucoup et donc
rendez vous au festival de loire du 20
au 24 septembre pour observer cette
oeuvre